ces accusations de désinformation
concernant la fiabilité des vaccins
américain contre la copie 19 ont été
qualifiés d' absurde et sans fondement
par le kremlin peskov a dit souhaiter ne
pas politiser le dossier de la
vaccination et tordre le cou aux rumeurs
qui circulent en particulier sur
internet
il a au passage signaler que le vaccin
russes aussi faisait l'objet
d'accusations fantaisistes
en général dans le monde
il y a une très grande discussion à
propos de l'ensemble des vaccins ceux
qui sont produits aux états unis au
royaume uni en inde en chine en russie
un vaste débat est en cours dans les
milieux scientifiques et dans les
milieux quasi scientifique ce dossier
anti fiq et dans les milieux politiques
match et que nous sommes toujours
opposés à la politisation de toute
question liée au vaccin
le vaccin doit passer les essais être
bien tester et dès que son efficacité
est confirmée il faut produire autant de
vaccins que possible pour sauver le
monde entier du coronavirus pour sauver
le plus grand nombre possible de vies
humaines
non notre vaccin est très efficace
mais malgré cela notre vaccin et
critiquer tous les jours parfois il
s'agit de critiques qui prétendent être
objective parfois de critiques infondées
sans aucune tentative de sembler
objective vladimir poutine lors d'une
allocution jeudi dernier avait défendu
les performances du premier vaccin russe
le spoutnik v face à la concurrence il
avait au passage évoqué les difficultés
et problèmes rencontrés en europe
pas certain des vaccins mais comme l'a
rappelé le porte-parole du kremlin
l'objectif dans cette crise sanitaire
mondiale est bien de produire en
quantité suffisante les meilleurs
vaccins afin de sauver le plus de vies
possible et c'est le chemin que tente
d'emprunter le scouting v alors que
celui ci est actuellement en train
d'être examinés par l' agence européenne
du médicament en vue de sa mise sur le
marché européen d'ici la fin du
printemps